es ist eine der härtesten ausbildung in
österreich rund 250 junge frauen und
männer durchlaufen im jahr die
ausbildung zum unteroffizier in der
heeres unteroffiziers akademie in enns
hier geht es auch um die ausbildung
weiterbildung und fortbildung der
unteroffiziere zu führungskräften 112
lehrgangsteilnehmer und sechs
lehrgangsteilnehmerinnen stehen in
diesem jahr kurz vor abschluss der
ausbildung des militärischen führung
lehrganges zweiten doch eine hürde gilt
es noch zu bewältigen
die sogenannte belastungs übung bei der
wohl die meisten an ihre körperlichen
und psychischen grenzen gehen werden
hier kann das trockene kleidung es ist
alles noch kleidung ausrüstung schon
alles
zwei wochen zuvor in enns also das ziel
der belastungs übung ist dass der hund
offiziersanwärter hinsichtlich seinen
führungsverhalten seiner
führungsfähigkeit im rahmen einer
regelgruppe das bedeutet mit bis zu
ungefähr acht personen und der
physischer sowie psychischer belastung
überprüft werden kann
er muss im rahmen der belastungs übung
er oder sie müssen im rahmen der
belastungs übung als kommandant
eingeteilt stationen bewältigen gefecht
technisch das bedeutet das was sie in
ihrer ausbildung erlernt haben umsetzen
können
stress wird dadurch erzeugt durch
zeitvorgaben oder schwierige
aufgabenstellungen sowie dann die
physische belastung durch die ständigen
schlafentzug und der marsch und das
gepäck wir begleiten zwei von insgesamt
zwölf gruppen bei der vorbereitung für
die belastungs übung
überhaupt mit der befehlsausgabe für den
gang stoff dessen gruppen kommen ist
herzogs kommunal und hat eingewiesen
kosten kommen ziel der heutigen übung
ist es dass jeder übungsteilnehmer und
jede übungs teilnehmerin als gruppen
kommandant eingesetzt einen gegenstoß in
der verteidigung im graben durchführen
kann
der kampf bevor nächste wirkungsbereich
ist dort draußen der schwergewichte
erwarten durch die visiereinrichtung
frau zugführer dürrer übernimmt als
erste die stelle der gruppen
kommandantin entschlossen und offizier
zu hören sei also ihren grundwehrdienst
macht in sankt michael bei megabad allen
ort sein
wir hatten ziemlich wollen woltron den
worten meister machen hab das alles
freiwillig gemacht
ob dann gleich wieder verlängert und
damit die kurse
die gelernte einzelhandelskauffrau hatte
keine lust mehr auf ihrem bürojob viel
spannender findet sie die ausbildung zum
unteroffizier im bundesheer erhofft sie
sich um mehr abwechslung als in ihren
bisherigen beruf bei ihrem ersten anlauf
als gruppen kommandantin macht die frau
zugführer die erfahrung wie wichtig es
ist sich auf die kameraden verlassen zu
können
als gruppen kommen das ist halt schwer
das alles umzusetzen über wenn man das
erste mal macht davor weil nur schütze
eigentlich immer bei einem gegenstoß und
jetzt selber als kommandant das alles zu
machen
es ist für was man denken muss man darf
nicht vergessen und das ist schon stress
situation machen
dazwischen drin war
ich habe die branche finden eigentlich
ein technik abgeschlossen bin daher vom
bundesrat genauso funker also war kein
schlägen tätig auch zugführer fröhlich
musste raus aus dem büroalltag ja
einerseits habe ich im grundwehrdienst
festgestellt dass mir ein bürojob
brauche ich nicht zu sagte schult er
meint und von daher hat man hier die
mischung aus draußen sein also in
gefäßen gemüse sowie als das technische
was dahinter steckt
die mischung macht nach den ersten
durchgängen gibt es auch schon ein
feedback vom ausbilder aber auch von den
kameraden viel besser in form kommt nur
kann man daten stimme ist auch immer
wieder zu lesen immer anlagen ausgeben
was das thema betrifft
und dann wird geschossen dann du musst
ich entweder dass man das versteht aber
sonst schon wesentlich besser werbung
sehe ich jetzt stark dass ich groß bin
und der größere schrittlänge
panaschieren leichter einerseits wurde
schwächen liegen könnten
weil ich weiss nicht wie und auch
dreifach schlafen zurück sie ist dann
der führungsfähigkeit gegeben ist
das sieht man an
bei der gruppe 2 wird ebenfalls der
gegenstoß geübt der unterschied die
umgebung
anstelle eines rahmens üben sie in einem
waldstück gruppen kommandantin am
heutigen nachmittag ist frau zugführer
pipeline
rang ab
betreibt hat versenkung
in der privatwirtschaft habe als die
blumen behindertenpädagogik audit ist
ein toller beruf mit menschen zusammen
weiß ist nicht zu vergleichen mit dem
beruf ist ganz besonderes markanten
geländekante werden wir nicht mehr meine
stärken während der belastungs übung
sieht definitiv erst in italien geht man
muss ja ob und so in kuba vor
ausschalten viele bereiche oder einiges
einfacher kopf noch sozialist maschine
dazu natürlich dass maschinen ab was
kann ich es mit meiner gruppe mit früher
oder später damit
das ist definitiv meine stärken
schwächen
ich werde sicher einige vielleicht beim
gefechts dienst käme darauf wer darauf
kommen dass sie dort noch defizite horn
die wurst zum ausbessern seien aber für
das bin jetzt die auf den kurs
wachtmeister lama setzt bei der
belastungs übung hingegen vor allem auf
seine körperliche fitness also bei der
belastungs übung sehe ich weniger das
problem bei der körperlichen belastung
im meer bei der psychischen belastung
also da durchbeißen wird sicher
schwierig aber ich sage wenn du ein
bisschen selbstvertrauen und biss durch
besser kann alles schaffen
auch hier soll ein feedback transparenz
schaffen und den übungs teilnehmern
helfen sich zu verbessern
aber sonst im großen und ganzen war
gefahren
der anlauf unter mitarbeit von allen
aufgabe war es ein gegenstoß mit meiner
gruppe durchzuführen stärker war einst
zu 72 70 einer gruppe happy face aufgabe
gemacht damit jeder informiert ist um
was es geht
wie ist lage waren auf druck kommen wir
als gruppe dann nach der befehlsausgabe
ist es gleich los gegangen sind der
gruppe erwägungen zum ersten
kontrollpunkt dort war noch keine
befehlsausgabe und damit wenig schützen
wissen wie du doch massierung ob dann
selber auf uns gestellt
das heißt jeder muskel zu arbeiten dann
schon losgegangen
wir haben sind da in chrom und landungen
um da wo wir jetzt stehen einen
gegenstoß durchführen zu können
es hat sich herausgestellt dass gemeint
aufgaben zu bewältigen man muss für
koordinieren heißt auf ganz viele sachen
zugleich schauen schauen als die
schützen ängsten dass alles läuft das
waffengesetz denn richtig bisher jeder
versteht was er machen muss
und natürlich ist es verbesserungswürdig
war für das er dort zum üben also ich
war am maschinengewehr amg war dort im
geschütze habt ihr einen zweiten
schützen bei mir und ich musste den
feind niederhalten die einstellungen
gehen ist haben wir dazu in meiner
stellung das beste draus machen müssen
und eben feuern enfernt bringen
dadurch dass ich da so gut ausgebildet
werde von meinem zugs komponenten und
meinen gruppen komponenten werde ich
sicher gut vorbereitet in die
belastungen gehen in unserer nächsten
folge stellen sich die unter
offiziersanwärter der belastungs übung
sie werden an ihre grenzen stoßen sie
überwinden oder ausscheiden
ob sich die vorbereitungen gelohnt haben
zeigen wir in folge 2
es tut schon weh mittlerweile
dokumentiert also mal spielt schon jetzt
endlich doch zum alle froh dass mainz
tor sein